alongside literature and Composition
oftentimes two parents ask questions
about grammar instruction and how that
can be implemented at home what
important to keep in mind is that
grammar structure is important if we're
going to have a mastery of the English
language just like any activity as based
on certain fundamentals certain key
building blocks and in order to be able
to do that thing well English grammar is
one of our roads to mastery in the
English language and something that we
ought to encourage with our students so
how can we instill grammar education at
home keep in mind that certain things
about grammar need to be memorized by
our students things like the parts of
speech and kinds of sentences are
preliminary pieces of information that a
students must know if they're going to
have a greater facility with the
language a good way to encourage us at
home is through sentence diagramming
there are multitude of resources online
they'll help you understand how to
diagram a sentence feel free to pull
these sentences from all sorts of things
maybe your student is reading a
particular novel or work of literature
and you want them to pull one other
sentences from there this could be a
great opportunity to take a very well
crafted sentence and break it down to
each of its constituent parts which ones
are the nouns which ones are the direct
objects which ones are the verbs and the
adjectives if you need a reminder about
the various parts of speech there's a
multitude of resources online beyond
simply identifying the various parts of
us of a sentence it's important to ask
your students how they know that
something is the noun or the verb or the
edge above we give an example while
grammar involves a lot of memorization
it's important that students understand
the reasons why particular parts of sons
function at the way that you do grammar
curricula that incur sense diagramming
such as well order language are great
resources to go to in order to help
facilitators jazz understanding of the
English language while it may not be as
exciting as literature a constant
instruction remember that grammar is an
important facet than at any student's
ability to master the English language
you